vous les mardis de légumes des fines
herbes et des fruits frais atterrissent
chez les argento l'été dernier le couple
a repéré les voisins qui comme eux ont
un potager une centaine en tout chaque
semaine nage un bon petit courriel me
dise a bâti des légumes oui et c'est une
bonne façon de rencontrer mais les gens
en ont quelque chose en commun du
jarnacais un petit potager qui en nous
se fait parfois trop généreux gens
pensent à des voisins de la famille mes
gars notre journée sort plus tous ces
surplus récolter les mardis domenico
argento ira les portes et le lendemain à
la mission old brewery au centre-ville
de montréal suzanne argento qui est
américaine a voulu importer l'idée
glanées dans un magazine est passé si
chaque personne autour des cmn seulement
1 tomate
on pourra voir centaines c'est leur
deuxième année l'a fait le mois de
septembre
on a quatre paniers mais l'initiative
citoyenne est venu aux oreilles de deux
producteurs de l'île perrot si bien que
les mardis domenico argento passe aussi
par là il y prend des légumes qui ne
trouveraient pas preneur si personne ne
se donnait la peine de venir les
chercher
la semaine passée la voiture qu apple à
la mission old brewery
on se souvient encore du succès de la
ratatouille de la semaine dernière
c'était vraiment avec kazuki est amarré
700 personnes c'est un cadeau plein de
fraîcheur dans cette cuisine habitués de
recevoir des fruits et légumes dont les
commerces qui ne veulent plus on sent
bon et sans jusqu'au mot fin puis un
produire tout de suite mais comme des
pros jeffrey on peut faire plus de choix
dans le même
c'est vraiment un thérapie pour moi je
trouve attention aux jardins chaque jour
une thérapie qui le mois d'août venu
fait aussi du bien à plein d'autres ici
à nourrice despatie radio-canada dickens
tirs